immer wieder werden in fiktive menschen
gezeigt deren raumanzügen platzen oder
die gar keine narben oder deren
raumschiff zerstört wird von einer auf
die andere sekunde hinter dem vakuum des
weltraums wehrlos ausgeliefert das sind
dann meistens nicht so schöne bilder
wenn sie platzen
verizon und so weiter aber ich habe mich
gefragt was passiert wirklich und wie
lange können wir das vakuum im weltraum
überleben
jetzt sind fix und 2006 herzlich
willkommen
ich stelle mir das schon ein wenig
unangenehm vor gerade noch im
schützenden raumanzug und dann plötzlich
der lebensfeindlichen umgebung
ausgeliefert die wir kennen wie lange
können wir das überleben haben wir
überhaupt eine überlebenschance würde
zum beispiel in der internationalen
raumstation eine luke zerstört werden
oder ein fenster platten wird es nur
sekunden dauern bis die gesamte atemluft
aus der raumstation endlichen wäre wie
crew wäre bevor dem vakuum ausgeliefert
und wenn jemand herausgeschleudert
worden wäre auch dem sonnenlicht wer
jetzt die luft anhält um den letzten
sauerstoff in der lunge zu behalten
der hat schlechte karten durch den
überzug lassen die luna als nächstes
fangen die körperflüssigkeiten an zu
kochen sie verdampfen
das hat mit dem niedrigen druck zu tun
kennt man vielleicht vom eierkocher
bürger auf 2000 metern höhe
zum beispiel brauchen wie eier länger
weiß aber schon deutlich unter 100 grad
celsius kocht jetzt fängt das blut an zu
kochen und der blutdruck bricht zusammen
das gehirn bekommt kein sauerstoff mehr
und bewusstlosigkeit tritt ein auch die
flüssigkeit in den fällen fängt an zu
kochen und sie platzen
dadurch werden flüssigkeiten gasförmig
und sammeln sich an verschiedensten
stellen im körper die dann wiederum
klassen aber davon wird man dann schon
lange nichts mehr mitbekommen im
schatten wenn es extrem kalt sein
nahe dem absoluten nullpunkt die
körpertemperatur sinkt also sehr schnell
das herz bleibt stehen in der sonne ist
allerdings genau andersrum
dort herrschen temperaturen von rund 100
grad celsius
das ist noch nicht alles man bekommt
nach wenigen sekunden einen heftigen
sonnenbrand die uv-strahlung der sonne
trifft die haut ungefiltert die
verbrennt sofort so oder so die
schlechte nachricht innerhalb weniger
sekunden wird man im weltall sterben
allerdings wie viele sekunden es exakt
sind kann niemand sagen es gibt gott sei
dank keinerlei erfahrung die gute
nachricht man wird nicht viel davon
mitbekommen
noch ist das keinen menschen widerfahren
allerdings gab es nur 60 bei der nasa
einen zwischenfall in einer vakuumkammer
der raumanzug einer testperson hatte ein
loch nach 14 sekunden war die person
bewusst dass das letzte an das er sich
erinnern konnte war dass die spucke auf
ihrer
zu kochen anfing also bei 37 grad zählt
wird im raumanzug heißt also eindruck
wie in rund 90 kilometern höhe über der
erde felix baumgartner sprang auf 39
kilometern höhe zu erde ohne seinen
anzug wäre ihm etwas ähnliches passiert
wie 15 sekunden später war die
vakuumkammer wieder voller luft die
testperson überlebte
wahrscheinlich herrschte in ihren
raumanzug nie ein vollkommenes vakuum es
ist also keine gute idee einen
weltraumspaziergang ohne raumanzug zu
versuchen wahrscheinlich würde man nicht
viel merken aber diese wenigen
empfindungen werden die letzten
empfindungen das leben sorgt das war der
erklärte für weltraumspaziergänge ohne
die geeignete kleidung wie meine mutter
schon sagte es gibt kein schlechtes
wetter es gibt nur falsche kleidung und
das gilt auch für den weltraum in diesem
sinne moment weitere spannende
informative nur ein blowing oder
sonstwie blasen videos bekommen wir
ausschließlich zu sehen wenn er mir hier
ein abo aufs auge drückt und nicht
vergesst mir einen auf die glocke zu
geben
dann verpasst ihr nämlich nichts hier
geht es weiter mit videos zum thema
weltraum tourismus falls ihr euch dafür
noch interessiert einfach drauf drücken
klicken oder was euer endgerät auch
immer von euch verlangt und jetzt
ansonsten bis dahin bleibt